hello guys and welcome to another video
so I haven't done a video like this for
a while but we have some huge news from
the manline season four and let me just
explain and show you what this news is
so with the release of season three
coming up soon it has been revealed that
John Favreau has written season four
already adding that he did so much work
on a fourth season during
post-production of the third so the
quote reads season four yeah I've
already written it we have to know where
we are going to tell a fully formed
story so we mapped it out Dave flony and
I and then slowly you just write each
episode so I was writing it during
post-production because all of it has to
feel like a continuation and one full
story so this is actually fantastic news
they're taking more of like a Marvel
preach to this where they've mapped out
a whole plan and where they want the
story to go and you know this is
something that really should have done
with a Star Wars sequel trilogy but
that's a complete other thing I'm not
going to get into but yes having it
mapped out and having a whole idea and a
whole plan of where they want this man
or in Sword to go he's just such a great
idea but yeah that is everything for
this video just a little bit of news I
wanted to report to you about the man
war in season four if you enjoyed this
video and you want more videos like this
do let me know in the comment section
below